you were accused during the trial of
taunting witnesses and bring them to
tears and inducing panic attacks how do
you reflect on that now you know when
you walk into a courtroom whether you're
a defense attorney whether you are
defendant whether you're a prosecutor or
a witness everyone has a role and a job
that they have to play and do and you
know when the women make allegations in
this case part of making allegations is
that your stories are challenged that's
what the American justice system looks
like you make a claim the defendant has
a right to something that we call the
Sixth Amendment right to confront your
accusers and you can ask questions to do
that you know the people that criticized
me I don't think they really think about
the big picture and I don't understand
what they were hoping for were they
hoping that we would let people walk
into a courtroom tell their stories and
not be asked any questions it doesn't
make any sense that's not how a court
procedure works the trial obviously had
little forensic evidence and zero
friends of government so it was down to
the testimony of these women and
ultimately that was accepted by the
jewelry do you accept that things are
changing in the way these kinds of cases
are tried if this becomes a pattern or a
model for the way juries decide cases I
think every single person who finds
themselves charged with the crime should
be concerned because if we are finding
people guilty where there are mountains
of doubt and very little evidence if any
at all I think we need to question what
the justice system looks like when you
have sexual assault cases the idea of a
woman coming to police with a test tube
of evidence just isn't realistic if it's
not true it's not true it's not about
realistic no but the question is do you
have to believe someone just because
they make a statement
there is a history of cases where women
don't tell the truth so to say that now
we should just believe women just
because they make a claim without any
evidence to back it up and actually
evidence to the contrary I think that we
have to be concerned about what what
these verdicts look like but false rape
accusations are tiny
you're speaking as though it's the
overwhelming majority I'm not speaking
I'm not speaking it's the overwhelming
majority you are speaking as if because
someone makes a claim it should be
gospel we have a system of justice in
the United States that says you are
innocent until proven guilty I'm sure I
don't need to remind you of the the
headlines that have been written about
you what kind of woman defends Harvey
Weinstein there's a special place in
hell for Weinstein's lawyer the me to
movement has a very loud voice has their
case in their argument ever made you
feel like you're a traitor to your
gender not at all I have a job to do I
believe in the system of justice that we
live under in the United States I think
that we have to fight hard to preserve
people's rights and I'll continue to do
that are you confident that you're on
the right side of history you know who
decides what that is I think that'll
happen I think that that determination
will have been long down the road may be
long after I'm gone if you're looking at
it from a more moral lens everyone's
guilty but that's not what we do in a
criminal justice system that's not how
it works they were guilty of a lot of
things they were guilty of using Harvey
Weinstein they were guilty of asking
Harvey Weinstein to do things making him
believe that they wanted to be with him
that they wanted to spend time with him
and then get up on a witness stand and
call him disgusting
sending him letter saying miss you big
guy sending letter saying love you lots
I mean how is that okay how are we as a
society saying men all bad women all
good when we look at that evidence how
do I know reconcile that did that
behavior worn sexually so we're talking
about two different things you're asking
me if the women were guilty I'm telling
you that they were guilty of certain
things no behavior warrants sexual
assault not the question here is whether
sexual assault took place given
everything else we know they need the
question no absolutely right coming
forward cannot be an easy decision the
things
datian it brings intense scrutiny it can
ruin a career surely a woman's not going
to do that unless she's telling the
truth I think that that's probably one
of the most ridiculous statements I've
ever heard there are so many reasons
people lie people lie in a regular basis
whether we're talking about sexual
assault whether we're talking about
whether or not they made a phone call
whether or not they showed up at work on
time people lie we live in a society of
people who lie so to say that that you
know we should only question people and
every other aspect of life but we should
never question them about sexual assault
you've seen these women up close it
doesn't look like they were having a
good time
no of course that that going to court is
not a good time for anyone wasn't a good
time for Harvey it's not a good time for
them being in a courtroom is never a
pleasant experience of course not it's
not a pleasant experience for anyone so
why would they put themselves through
that if they're not telling that let's
see what happens after this this
sentencing tomorrow and we'll see how
many people file lawsuits against Harvey
Weinstein it is such a radical position
to believe women to have that as the
foundation it is not a radical position
to believe people on the surface level
about anything it's not a radical
position but to say that you should
believe a statement that someone makes
without challenging in any way when you
have evidence to the contrary that's
very dangerous is what I'm saying so can
you imagine if we lived in a society
where we say well everything everybody
says we must believe if there are other
factors taken into account here surely
the volume of allegations has to play a
role it plays a role in the court of
public opinion it should not play a role
in the courthouse where you're looking
for justice in a criminal case you said
that you have never been sexually so
crossed because you've never put
yourself in that situation so are you
implying that there is choice in being
sexually assaulted I am implying that
there is choice in the circumstances in
which we put ourselves so you think
there are things that women can and
should do
it's that chances of a sexually assaults
absolutely I think just as when we walk
down the street we take precautions and
we get in the car we put a seatbelt on
we take precautions I think it would
behoove all of us to take precautions
when we're putting ourselves in
circumstances that we think might be
tenuous just accepting the world where
there are sexual predators and it's up
to women
no I'm a realist I'm not at all I'm not
at all I'm accepting of a world that bad
things happen in it's unrealistic to
think that it doesn't what about the
man's role in this the man's role who
holds the power certainly in this
situation I don't think you men have any
power anymore says I can further your
career I don't think I don't think men I
know I don't think men have any power
anymore how does a man have power today
if a woman can say anything she wants
and they're gonna be believed that takes
away every ounce of power that a man has
the pendulum is swinging so far in
another direction that I think it's
dangerous and scary and nobody's gonna
change my mind about that how everyone
seems being called a monster a predator
how would you describe Harvey Weinstein
is a wickedly intelligent person who has
worked very hard who has sacrificed a
lot of things for the expense of
perfection and making great movies I
think that he would be the first one to
say that he made mistakes and in
sacrificing time with family and friends
in the pursuit of greatness and you know
success and in the business world he has
never been anything but kind to me to
the defense team he's grateful to us I
don't have I don't have negative words
to say about Harvey Weinstein I didn't
have a negative experience with him I
found him to be very easy to work with
actually and frankly I think whatever is
going to happen to him tomorrow will
will make me sad